going out and uh looking for kids to
hand out lunchables too
[Music]
you want lunchable bud
what's your name
[Music]
nice to meet you
we'll come by here more often okay
all right
i love this this is your chance to give
police a ticket but it's not what you're
thinking metro police foundation the
sponsors of this segment are giving
members of the community a way to
recognize officers for some of the
positive things they're doing in the
community here to talk more about that
we have metro officer samuel whitwer and
lori cauldron executive director of
community engagement at resorts world
thank you both for being here
let's start with you officer whitwer you
are being honored for what we just saw
there you are you you have uh managed to
collect food and you've purchased some
with your own money to distribute to a
lot of the people you see out in the
community yeah it's it's a great thing
that i'm able to be a part of and
started it up and it's a great way to
see the kids
out there and you know in their
apartments and see them in a different
different light well it's especially
important i would think during the
summer months when they don't have
access to school lunches and everything
else that they do during the school year
yeah and definitely during covid
all the schools were shut down it was
hard to get them food and that's kind of
where we really started to do this
and i you know wanted to get the kids
some food and saw him hungry out playing
outside and was like hey what can we do
and got together with the community
leaders and
got them some lunchables and got to have
fun with them and
get to see him in a different
aspect than just police work it's a
fantastic idea lori you at resorts world
obviously love the idea as well why was
it important to get involved
resorts world las vegas is really proud
to sponsor with the las vegas
metropolitan police department and to
sponsor the good ticket program and for
us it's such a wonderful thing to be
part of this whole experience and
ceremony and for us to be able to come
and and and speak to this amazing
officer who really goes above and beyond
and puts his heart into his work every
day and i think it's so great to be able
to share these stories that we hear with
everyone yeah i do too and i think
especially at a time when there's a
divide in many sectors it's just great
to see this kind of outreach i think
it's so great so thank you for your
service to the community and also thank
you for the extra mile that you're going
to help kids and others in the valley
and laura you have a certificate to
present i do i'm really excited to uh
present you with a staycation
to resource world so um you know that
has the information you can
come and
stay whenever you like so when you need
a break
and have someone maybe take care of you
and treat you to some things you just
let us know and then we do have the
metropolitan police department good
ticket so i'm going to give you a ticket
thank you so much welcome i appreciate
it
officer
congratulations i just think it's great
what you're doing and lori thank you for
recognizing it and thank you very much
to the attention of the community right
all right thank you both and we want to
thank again the las vegas metropolitan
police department foundation for
sponsoring this segment and you can get
more information
on how this program works by visiting
lvmpdfondation.org
rocky